that was a real delayed one it was kind
of like a network three two and then the
one went away
Marcus rightfully assumed oh we must be
on she was like 100 you just saw
backstage ladies it's not happening
welcome welcome welcome to fat man be on
I'm Kevin Smith and I am mark barnard oh
crap look at us right here at the scum
and villainy canteen on a Thursday note
no fun Holi no on Hollywood Boulevard
here in Hollywood used to be thriving
particularly this time you made it here
in three minutes from my house [ __ ]
ghost town out there this is the thing
I've noticed today that's new in town
every crosswalk they now got a sign
hanging up saying do not touch the
button oh wow the lights will go
automatically so I was like why are they
putting that up my kids like why do you
[ __ ] think and I was like oh they
don't want people touching the button
why don't they put up a sign that just
says this [ __ ] never worked this was
always a mind trick and now [ __ ]
we're letting you it's just Frogger do
you guys don't work
it is quiet out there in Hollywood
ladies and gentlemen so quiet as quiet
in your neck of the woods it's a little
less quiet I think that only because
there are still people who you know have
to get to the essential jobs that they
have there's still people out walking a
lot you know just I gotta get my steps
in I gotta be active I'm on me you don't
do that I did it early on like I did it
when I was 16 once
yeah it's overrated I walked a place
that I got a job and I don't do that
anymore
got a license [ __ ] walk it's just that
out by where I live it's now 110 degrees
it's [ __ ] tough today
wait so was it legit 110 it was a
hundred and two yeah I saw there was 93
at one point I called my mother I was
walking like up the hill just doing my
walking and [ __ ] and I didn't realize
like oh my god it [ __ ] got hot
normally I go in earlier in the morning
but I didn't wind up going to like one
o'clock and I brought my dog with me
Shecky and she [ __ ] quit like two
blocks and she was like take me home and
so I went and did it myself I was
talking to my mother
and I realized you know before I reached
the top which is Mulholland that it was
probably a good buy mom call and it was
so hot my mother's going Tiger just turn
around and go down the hill as a cat
it's must rocky through this in a
montage mom yeah it was [ __ ] hot
today it's no [ __ ] joke and like you
can kind of hear you know I went outside
to get a delivery of something that
showed up at the house I don't know yet
because I always let the boxes sit for
like a day really unless unless it's
foodstuffs you hear that porch pirates
rolled by Marc's house gonna steal all
you want they're like no no three more
hours on that package I don't let it sit
outside I just bring it inside and let
it sit crazy as science is that though
you're like we wait a a day because at
some point early on and it's probably
since been debunked but that it it
couldn't the the the cocoa the virus
cocoa viral couldn't persist on just
objects and so like if you didn't if you
let it sit it would die off if it was on
there to begin with and whatever you
need in there you get just as good
tomorrow as you did today
that's probably [ __ ] but it still
sounds like [ __ ] in the beginning we
started microwaving it every box we got
ting a box that got delivered sticking a
microwave but we forgot we ordered
microwave popcorn that really [ __ ] up
that just write jokes now kids like a
bit a little bit alright we've got so
much show to give you ladies we
gentleman there's always news Mark's dug
up news but we're not gonna get to that
what we've been doing lately is having
guests at the top of the show and I
gotta be honest with you in terms of
like you know nobody wants this it's
terrible particularly with all the death
and stuff thank you for everyone who's
out there on the front lines working so
we can not the only time we risk
ourselves when we come to this empty bar
show no it depends who you ask but you
know yeah we're not truly an essential
service we the one good thing that's
come out of this though is we've figured
out that we can [ __ ] have anybody be
a guest
jaesi at some point had rigged this bar
to be able to do this and we never used
it never we always talked about like one
day we should have people Skype in yeah
yeah one day but it's always easier to
have a [ __ ] lean on the wall and
hit him with a camera and it was always
they like well Kim's gonna be on tour
for like six months yeah we could just
Skype it at the top of every show like
checking with Kara on the road never did
that never happened I could have been on
every episode of life but maybe I could
have been here here your type man who
opens the show Hannah ladies and
gentlemen give it up for Bach is himself
Martin you could have been our senior
white correspondent that's right
reporting from the road Here I am in
Tennessee mark how do you think things
are here what's the weather like white I
thought so yeah I'm the future rocket
man we're gonna have everybody oh yeah
I'm gonna start hitting [ __ ] the future
we might just keep doing it like I was
driving here today going like I know a
guy who played Batman I should ask him
if he wants to escape looking in yeah be
one thing if it's like hey man can you
come down to the bar I mean I don't know
dude people might you know recognize me
stuff like that but here but here we
give them Skype of men yeah pants on I'm
going through my [ __ ] rolodex this
week hell yeah I'm gonna find everybody
and just be like Thor's yeah
Chris Hemsworth can you Skype with us
he's such a nice guy he might say yes
you're a thing mate well you need yeah
be like oh my god I feel so bad because
he's so Australian and nice he just says
yes and [ __ ] like that but for you Chris
yeah 3 o'clock a.m. - I am Mike wait how
is it down America and oh my god I'm so
sorry but yeah we could do this did you
see he did the Netflix watch along for
his Netflix movie and after an hour they
were like Chris you can go he was like
no I'll stay he's a good boy raised
right that kid oh that would you do
watch that Netflix mom I haven't seen it
yet
extraction bonkers it just it doesn't
stop like it's it is a [ __ ]
relentless action movie man it's good
it's really good like it reminds me of
that like as I watched I was like holy
[ __ ] I wish my father was alive
because this would be his favorite movie
of all time like this is a perfect film
why can't you make [ __ ] like extraction
that's what I'd be hearing and stuff
chasing amy [ __ ] out extraction
chasing Hemsworth he's doing the chasing
now that's an action movie cab it is
really good it was legit good but yeah
so anyway since we've been doing this
we've learned we have the ability to
Skype in guests the power to cloud men's
minds with a [ __ ] Skype or zoom of a
guest coming in so going forward let's
do more of this yeah hey East Coasters
you know like [ __ ] you know we should
talk to like everybody I don't know why
we're limiting ourselves like metropolis
people from Gotham [ __ ] [ __ ] om ko
City I could blew up depending on what
your comics you're talking about but we
could get some East Coast folks chiming
in and stuff Scott Snyder you know like
hell yeah getting people that like work
on a [ __ ] who we have heard over the
years like the show but you know getting
to Cumberbatch from London we can get
like international [ __ ] I don't
know if we can get him but I do know
Scott Mosier and Benedict Cumberbatch
Cumberbatch was a voice in the grinch
movie Scott do me a favor give me good
Benedict Cumberbatch numbers like are
you [ __ ] kidding me I'm like you know
clean great get your phone he goes next
week you trying to cast him in a movie
once go through your agent like no I
want him on my pocket well me on your
bug is there's a dude who knows a thing
or two about podcasting Scott you know
you're but he's been in the trenches
been in the trenches but I'm sure he'd
be like hey man just started my
directing career am I gonna [ __ ] blow
it so you get have some Skype buddies
one Kalb Affleck um like maybe I will
I'm pre having this fight so it's gone
don't have to have it when I asked him
for Benedict Cumberbatch's number you're
gaming it out this is this is your one
finger you're holding up totally I've
went through 14 million [ __ ] versions
of reality and there was only one and
which Scott was like here's Benedict
Cumberbatch's number don't abuse it I
was like all right and then we Skype
them so we'll be doing it more
or yeah we did it of course we had Jim
Leon I was exciting we had Steve jeppie
last week that was great tonight we got
another guest man we're gonna do we have
our guest should I give you a heads up
probably dialing our guest up JC sitting
at the table as you see him ladies John
the loneliest bar owner in the world Sam
alone sitting right there
his Diana's at home I'm here on
ourselves dollars there you go oh but
you know we'll get right to it that so
of course as per usual kids like you
know it's we're just crowing about we
can have guests but you know we're
figuring [ __ ] out of a wheel as we go
yeah totally so it's not like
technically [ __ ] insanely technically
proficient although most of the late
night shows i've been told from an
inside source are also not like you know
[ __ ] they're zooming and skyping but
they live
there's nothing not a lot a lot and this
is the one thing that blew my hair back
is something i heard this week there's a
department that they got now where
they're just erasing digitally erasing
ear pods from everybody's ears because
in order to do it they always tell you
like you got to put in headphones
otherwise you hear the echo like we
heard and stuff so people are naturally
putting it in their ear pods and stuff
and i don't know if it's because they're
like I don't want to get a free [ __ ]
commercial not [ __ ] Apple or if
they're just like this looks tacky this
looks weird but whatever they've started
erasing the ear pods from people seems
like such a catastrophic waste of money
right like with with I don't care how
much you spent like let's say it's 200 a
pop a lot of late night guests that [ __ ]
like that it's more than that because
you gotta have one [ __ ] and
frame-by-frame erasing earpods true that
seems like let Apple have a little bit
of we all know what they are are yeah no
doubt what are you hiding it's not like
they got dick and balls on them or
something like that it's an ear pod for
having sex unless they got their very
special custom the dick and balls your
scrotum that some people like to get
stickers you seem long around dangling
balls and stuff like that like oh that's
blinged out yeah and festive so yeah man
lucky enough
we figured out our tech stuff and
mercifully we got a legit guest man we
got true talent joining us on the show
tonight ladies and gentlemen there is a
TV show that's beginning very soon yes I
think within weeks within seconds I
think it begins in May right it says new
CW show and it's made by our friend Jeff
Jon's man and it's based on a character
that Jeff created while he was writing
comics of DC and stuff and the show of
course is star girl you know let's watch
a clip
I'm kidding we don't have that ability
where you pull out my phone give a trail
hold it up to the camera mark if you
haven't seen it you can jump over and
pull up another window go to YouTube and
stuff pull up a trailer and you can
watch it while this is going on show
looks absolutely phenomenal man it was
originally I think going a DC Universe
and now it's CW full CW which is like
huge for the show but we get to speak to
the title character tonight ladies
gentlemen the actress responsible for
star girl you've seen her in the spots
perhaps you've seen the episodes that's
not some people online did get to see it
already like I guess I guess you know
like tastemaker critics and show yeah
tastemakers but you you know or you love
her she's your star girl and she's gonna
be your star girl for the next few years
you know fingers crossed man those CW
shows run forever
yeah they don't go oh my god those
supernatural boys they're 96 and they've
been doing that show since they were in
their 20s so you're seeing somebody
tonight who is gonna be on the CW long
after we all pass away the next 75 years
for the next 75 years the face of the CW
is going to be tonight's guest star girl
herself give it up for Breck basking
area Basinger you there Breck how are
you oh well it's a star matron by that
point I think I know what no but no
because just just because she ages
they're gonna keep a girl girls
marketable the Supergirl Melissa she's
like 86 and they still call that show
girl Golden Girls brackets a president
how excited are you man you're about to
join the ranks of all the heroes at CW
and with with your own darn show how how
does this feel man it's hard to find the
words to describe the feeling um like
you said I didn't know was going on CW
from the beginning because it was
supposed to originally just be DC
Universe which is a great streaming
service but now that we're on both it's
that much bigger that much better can't
find where I'm so excited also I've been
working on it for almost two years at
this point and so it's time I'm ready
for the world to see it take us back
what do you mean almost two years that
when you got cast yes so it was
September of 2018 and so when did you
guys shoot your pilot February of 2019
so like last year right on and so now
how many of you guys like on I know on
the other CW shows they're generally
like five episodes out or something did
you guys because it was going to be on
DC Universe did you shoot like your
entire run already is are you guys done
yeah we finished back in September so
it's been locked and finished for a
couple months now at this point I
actually think it was the last episode
we were filming we found out about going
on the CW oh wow now those uh those the
the kids in those CW shows man work like
crazy like grant you know when you're
the main character they can't do a scene
without you even when you're not you
know the in your hero outfit you're
they're following the secret identity
story so grant works constantly Melissa
one of the most overworked human beings
I've ever met in my life because she's
super girls you've never seen it stuff
yeah I would imagine with a title like
star girl you're you're on deck every
damn day you don't get a day off do you
during the shoot yeah our shooting
schedule was insane
we tended to start in Mondays at 5:00
a.m. and our Trickle day was 14 hours so
5:00 a.m. to 7 p.m. and throughout the
week with the 12-hour turnaround which I
was
lucky enough to get most days by the
time we got to Friday we called them
Frogger days and we'd work like 5 p.m.
to 7 a.m. day and then Monday morning
5:00 a.m. again I think there was one
day I counted how many hours I worked
that week and it was in the 80s because
we had like a 6 day workweek as well and
I'd have like two 20-hour days and a 17
hour day and it was just it was crazy
and there you know some people out there
going oh how bad gonna be or make it
pretend for a living when you're the
main character in a show and that show
has action and adventure in it it's not
as simple as like I'm gonna sit here and
talk to you like that's the fun and easy
part we're like here do dialog and stuff
like that but then when they're like
alright we need to do this sequence all
time slows down in order to make an
action sequence you are shooting
repetitively and whatnot and sometimes
like in the case of Melissa they put her
on harnesses and there's a lot of wire
work in Stargirl too so you have you
been up on the wire throughout the whole
like costume shows from mid-drift
so they had to make like a custom
harness so it could function properly
yeah yeah I got well accustomed to that
harness we would try to like in between
takes try to take it off because I would
have bruises all over my hips in adult
diaper essentially looks like and and
the thing is like they put it on you and
you know it's not like hey we'll be done
in a half hour like you're in it for
hours at a time they'll bring you down
periodically and then it's like alright
you're going back up and they hoist you
up in the air man do you get scared like
I'm a Heights person so I hate that kind
of stuff how is it being hoisted up I'm
an adrenaline junkie like I went
skydiving the day I turned 18 so I the
one time I got scared is thy was
supposed to do a backflip off of stripe
the robot who's 16 feet tall and I got
up there and I didn't want but I like I
didn't fully go for I backed out in the
very middle of it and that's like the
last thing you should do and after that
I was like okay I don't I don't feel
comfortable doing this anymore so that
was
the one stunt that like it was height
with wire with a backflip and I I wasn't
ready there my skills were not well take
us all the way back to the beginning
tell us how the role came to you driving
actress without work and I mean it was a
pretty standard audition process it was
actually very very quick I think I only
had four auditions I mean you hear of
some of the auditions that they go for
ten eleven different audition sequences
but um it was just four is very simple
after the screen test which was kind of
like the final stage I was on my way to
the airport because I was supposed to be
in the Bahamas and I extended my trip a
day so I could go to the screen test and
I get a call from a random number that I
don't have saved and he I enter and it's
like hi this is Jeff and like Jeff he's
like yeah I just wanted to let you know
that you're our star girl before you
went on vacation I started bawling I
hadn't let myself get excited because I
feel like as an actress it's it's just
so easy to get excited and have it taken
away from you like see the future and so
I didn't let myself get excited so I
finally heard Jeff John say you're our
star girl and then it will hit me and
then I went and had a great vacation
I mean like it's good enough you're
going to the Bahamas they're like by the
way here's a cherry on top feel like
life is grand for star girl that Bahamas
would have made losing the park probably
a little easier but and how nice that
you got the part you mentioned before
stripe is his height what did you say 14
16 feet and is that like in the show
they did I guess my question is did they
build a robot or is it all CG there is a
practical robot they have the full the
full 16 foot strike and then they have
his torso up which we did a lot of like
if I was riding on his back or something
he would use that and then a lot of it
was visual effects as well like there's
a part in the second episode where I
climb up him it's very like iron
and I on the day I was climbing up
basically a ladder and so I have seen it
and to see the way it looks my
imagination did not on the day was not
as extravagant as it ended up being I
got to imagine this probably the most
strenuous job you've had of all your
acting gigs and also probably the most
time-consuming being that you are on set
all the time yeah the hardest but also
the most rewarding and this is what
everybody wants right like the idea when
you become an actor and actors she's
like oh my god I would love to be the
lead in something to get that call you
know especially from like the show
creator and it puts it so nicely to be
like you're our star girl and stuff what
a magical way to begin the job deep were
you very familiar with DC books at all
like star girl relatively new creation
so it's not like you know there's a deep
cuts library to go through and probably
not a lot of people like in your world
but like I've been reading star girl for
years or something like that so did you
have to go some deep-diving yeah I found
a couple of the stars and stripes that
I've now read
but I didn't know a lot before but
throughout the show I've gotten to learn
more about star girl as well as the JSA
because there's a lot of JSA I assay in
this first season I mean yeah yeah
Jeff's way deep into the like nerdy
continuity stuff man he goes deep he did
in his books make sense that he doesn't
in the shows what he worked with Luke
Wilson a lot was how is he he's great
we're both from Texas so we kind of like
bonded over that I remember the first
time I met him I was so nervous actually
the first time I met him was the first
time I went to go see stripe and it was
on Jeff John's birthday so that's a very
memorable day and I remember being so
nervous cuz I grew up watching Legally
Blonde loving that movie that's one
thing I knew him from I don't even know
if he knows that and I had looked up and
saw that he was from Texas I'm like okay
Brock I'm gonna try to make a connection
with him I was like oh yeah how about
them Dallas Cowboys nope he likes the
Cowboys he's a Cowboys fan but it just
fell flat um
he's definitely one of those people I
think he's more
introverted and yes like warm up to you
but throughout the season like he
totally did that and by the end we were
so close like he has such a special
place in my heart he's a really great
dude
what how many episodes in the first
season 13 and you guys were fully not
intending to go to CW but it winds up
like a 13 episode orders like a half
season that's good are you prepared to
make the jump into CW stardom the fan
base for the air over shows and for all
the CW DC shows rabid to say the very
least
wonderful supportive bless you without
them like you know that those shows
don't rise man and they've they rise and
like we said before you jumped on they
run them forever and stuff are you ready
to be a CW kid I'm excited I don't know
I don't know how you can be ready for
something like that like how am I
supposed to prepare I'm a little nervous
because I know comic book fans in
particular can be very specific to what
they have pictured and imagined and I
want to like meet their expectations so
there's a little bit of nerves when it
comes to that I mainly just excited not
prepared excited I mean Jeff Jones I
think is the biggest fan of this
character to begin with him he created
it as a tribute to his late sister um
how is the process been working and
discovering the character and working
through with Jeff Jeff I mean you all
know him he is he is one of the most
special people I've ever met in my life
not even gotten to work with but just
met period well I feel like where's our
girl comes from the meaning behind her I
did feel some pressure because I feel
like I want once again I feel like he
has expectations for what this role
means and I wanted to live up to them I
wanted to do this for him and he's just
so gracious and kind I feel like any
pressures I had towards that I'm
specific he just went away he's so
complimentary um and when it comes to
like the comics like I read those and he
was like yes follow those but don't
worry forward take not
Courtney because I don't like in volume
1 into like she's very uh almost spunky
rude and while she's still happy with
that we we found like a new version of
her did he warn you what the I mean
we're not gonna get any comic book
conventions I don't think this year
maybe the end of it what did he warn you
a bit about what it might be like going
to a convention as the CW's new star
girl people just keep saying it's gonna
be crazy like they can't find words to
describe you're just not gonna be able
to believe it there's gonna be people
dressed up as you and I've already like
seen a couple people like I've been
tagged on Instagram and people in
Stargirl cosplay which is crazy my mom
said she wants to dress up a star girl
for Halloween but she said she has to
work on her ABS what what do what his
mom think about all this I mean look I
I've done nothing in life and my mom's
super proud
you must get be somebody's pride and joy
I assumed I was under 18 so my mom
traveled back and forth between Texas
with me and she truly is my biggest fan
to like the extent when she moved back
home to Texas I was like mom you need to
take home some of these pictures and
magazines of me because I can't have a
shrine in my own apartment to myself
she's like yeah but it's so good Mike
yeah that's great for you but I can't do
that mother and she's like okay fine I
understand she truly is my biggest day
my grandma might have her beat it's a
good competition but I've gotten the
first five episodes of star girl I
shouldn't I'm not supposed to have
shared them with her but it Jack knows
like I share everything with her I think
she's watched them about ten times each
at this point and going up she's the one
that's spoiling him on the internet and
stuff she's like I've seen five episodes
let me tell you what happens she's not
telling me about and she's trying to
just spoil it for everyone yeah what at
the end of the day what are you hoping
that you know look it's a show that
could be enjoyed by everybody but
with the main character being star girl
clearly like you're gonna be out there
front and center for a bunch of a spurt
of little girls watching the show what's
your hope to get through to them that
new potential new audience people kids
that may grow up watching you yeah I
think that's one of the special things
about star girl is because it does have
such diversity just like with the
demographic of the show like it could be
very young but also I feel like adults
could enjoy it um I think the thing I
want is relatability
that's what's something I really was
important to me in star girl and
Courtney because she's just a high
school teen so even though she's a
superhero she's still going through like
the normal teen difficulties and I hope
I hope there's some girls out there that
can relate to her and see themselves in
her now have you been doing since we're
all locked down and whatnot and the show
is about to happen obviously like you're
here on our show have you been doing a
round of press and is that all this is
it all zoom do you have you been in a
room with anybody or is it all on a
laptop at this point in that amazing I
mean you're gonna get spoiled man cuz
one day they're gonna be like no you
have to go into CNN to do an interview
you can be like why what is it there's a
fat man be on poster on the wall behind
you it was that whatever I I like
drawing I'm RT cool quirky and I drew
because I was watching the name is
flipping me but I was watching an
interview that y'all did and I noticed
in the background
y'all's background I was like I'm gonna
like pretend I'm in studio even though
I'm not home man [ __ ] background yeah
way to insert yourself into the
proceedings we appreciate that that's
very cool find your life what are you
quarantine in Los Angeles or in Texas
what do you miss home or were when you
left was it like I'm ready to start my
life elsewhere home at this point um
there's parts of Texas that I miss like
I miss my family a lot but I California
like sunny California the beach the
weather the people I just this is home
so none of the things you can take
advantage of right now any minute now
they're gonna let us have all those
things back though all the reasons we
moved to California exactly how how has
your quarantine been overall pretty
pretty good I'm an introvert at heart
okay this is actually probably the
biggest lesson I took from Stargirl from
Amy Smart who plays my mom because I'm
I'm almost 21 but I like my friends
would invite me to go out and was like
that sounds exhausting and I always felt
weird about it because I'm like oh
something's wrong with me like I'm a 20
year old that doesn't want to go party
and she told me she's like I think I
think you're an introvert like no but I
have social skills I swear if you're an
introvert that means you gain your
energy by yourself and if you're an
extrovert you've gained your energy with
people and like oh that's me that that
makes sense
and so honestly I am like more focus and
more energetic than I've been in such a
long time because I've spent so much
time by myself you've had enough time to
draw logos on your back wall yeah I mean
heavens she's an artist man leave her
alone is if it's not acting as strong
it's crap regards she has chosen wisely
yeah no doubt what what are you looking
forward to doing most once they let us
all go back out into the real world I
really I mean I guess you mentioned
that's the second time and like it's
I've been here 18 years whatever I lived
here
I've never gotten the beach once like I
know I mean I think I've seen the pier
of Jonathan like why would they go down
there
that's no I agree it's a little touristy
but I grew up on it on the water so
maybe it doesn't appeal to me I guess
text is pretty landlocked so like the
idea of a beach well not all of its land
like huge Gulf of Mexico the really pure
far from the Gulf get out of here really
yeah it's huge man I'm driving but it's
got character it's like one of those
places like New Jersey or like Ohio
Aloha like South Dakota yeah you know
just like good old SD it has a currency
to and the credibility where you're like
oh I'm from Texas people go oh and they
just listen just a little bit more same
things at night are big and bright deep
in the heart of Texas absolutely it is
it's the whole world is gonna change for
you you've done stuff before man but
like this is fandom this is genre this
is comics once you get into this world
it's it's a different fan base the
people that you reach with star girl who
fall in love you fall in love with the
show are people that you will be seeing
for the rest of your life Breck I assure
you you'll and I'm not even saying our
conventions they'll come up to you like
wherever you are in the world and tell
you how important you being star girl
was to them as a kid and stuff like that
it's nuts it'll chase you all throughout
your life man because people love
superhero shows particularly these CW
shows and stuff you're well positioned
kid congratulations you got anything
else for Brecker can we let her go I
don't I think we should let her go
Breck what night does it debut on the CW
star girl May 19th so we got a couple
weeks ladies and gentlemen outstanding
get ready
brand new DC heroine joining us and when
I say heroine I don't mean the the you
know the Y powder stuff I'm talking
about a super heroine with a giant robot
and an e at the end that's right that
other heroine one of the good
goody Thank You breakfa making the time
on a Thursday night man look forward to
watching it and so hey let me ask you
this I know they do multiple episodes of
the show do they need a director next
season you ask somebody can you ask
somebody over there I met Jeff a few
times he might remember me pass on my
name my house is going through a tunnel
damn it why is this always happen to me
thank you so much for being here tonight
everyone give it up for breakfast adjure
ladies Congrats star girl how awesome is
that it was so it's got our whole life
in front of us you and me
almost dead yep almost finished it's all
downhill from here we're all finished
look at her she's just starting out her
bright shining life and stuff that's
awesome she's cool man she's funny you
know she's a you you wouldn't think that
she was 20 years old in her first like
starring role in a TV show that girl is
20 she's 20 um I'll tell you what
[ __ ] like almost stopped my heart I
almost had a second [ __ ] heart attack
when she was like Amy Smart plays my mom
I'm like what okay hold on what do you
mean your mother and I guess like that
tracks like you smart she's not 12 no oh
yeah that's crazy we've all grown up I
look forward to watching that that
sounds [ __ ] dope man yeah I'm always
happy for Jeff too he's such a [ __ ]
good guy such a nice guy and I know how
much that characters meant to himself
and I could hear I you know did you like
when she described him calling up be
like I just want to tell you before you
go on your vacation you're our star girl
that is such like a Geoff Johns classy
move you know what I'm saying like most
people in the studio be like well we'll
talk about this and like we'll get back
to them on Monday or whatever here's
this she's about to go way back and
stuff like that and you know vacations
cool and take your mind off and stuff
but no matter what you're doing you're
gonna be thinking about I wonder if I
got that Martin stuff and he's just
human enough humane he's a [ __ ]
humanist to like put her out of her
misery but like it did get it now enjoy
your [ __ ] vacation could you imagine
me in that having that kind of wonderful
first world life oh my god I want that I
want that magic [ __ ] did you ever get a
phone call that where somebody was like
I choose you like for a job
or whatever we always just hired in a
room no I got I've gotten calls like
that I've also gotten calls on vacation
saying we're laying you off I remember
that feel like I've been to the other
side of that expect hope you enjoyed the
first half of your vacation because I'm
about to change your life that's true
she had the opposite situation but you
used to have been where you were away no
like by the way keeps keep vacating yeah
just don't come back if you don't want
yeah you ain't got no point you're done
ship your [ __ ] to your house that's fine
um how nice man that's that's [ __ ]
dope I look forward to watching that it
was nice meeting somebody on the rise
Yeah right like think about it's
probably like he's gonna work forever
and [ __ ] we're gonna be old man one day
[ __ ] maybe should be like didn't you
guys talk to me in the bar online as
she's winning an Oscar remember you drew
us on your wall did she draw us learn to
draw so did she copy it I think well I
think she drew us man I think it was
like an old-school Batman it was it was
the old art work grams it was fat man on
Batman yeah I mean that's deep cut or
deep cuts in legit and she added herself
to the artwork you'll be hearing from
our [ __ ] lawyers her lawyers are
better than our lawyers she got those
both both of the brothers Warner's and
his sister Gaia they got both cons
Country and Western all right man
that was wonderful lot more of that
[ __ ] right oh yeah like you know that
was how long was that Jacey 18 minutes I
don't know well you keeping you in a
turtle clock like I don't know maybe 10
maybe 15 20 maybe you know it's not too
much of an imposition no we didn't seem
like she was like god I want to get the
[ __ ] off this like yeah and she died so
grotesque shouldn't have to fly to New
York to do it either
you know what I'm saying that is some
couch time right there I'm just start
reaching out to people and [ __ ] right
here I've met some cats man this is my
Booker this is my chance to find out how
much people really don't care for me
there's been 20 minutes with me on the
couch ya know there was I mean this is
maybe I should not you know it's not bad
story so who's the dude who is in
legends of tomorrow and he played dr.
Stein Oh Victor Garber Victor Garber
well excellent [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ] I
didn't know that was in there who knows
what else you're capable of Victor
Garber the great Victor Garber who rose
on legends of tomorrow I have been a
huge Victor Garber fan my whole life Wow
my whole life going back to when I was a
kid he played Anthony the sailor in the
original production of Sweeney Todd you
are such a theater kid he was also Jesus
and God spelled the movie and you know
as a Catholic and I loved theater he's
so like [ __ ] God spell was huge and
stuff I've been watching his cat in like
stuff my whole life and stuff always
been a fan and when he was on you know
legends those are all weak crappy it's
Jesus you know so it's around Argo and
he's in Argo and so you know I'm I'm
podcast I've been podcasting for what's
13 years now so I was podcasting then
and podcast was rather popular spod Cass
and I had cool people on so I said you
know I always wanted to blow that guy up
man because like [ __ ] Anthony the
Sailor like you know you you nobody
knows this musicals movie but like
that's a really dense yeah so I was like
I would love to [ __ ] [ __ ] out of them
and now he's on you know legends or
whatever to [ __ ] but more importantly I
was like oh he's at Argo and so that'll
help promote the movie and stuff so I
was like reach it can you reach out to
you know Victor Garber's people and see
if he'll come to a podcast and stuff had
the word came back like no not even like
oh he's not available right now it was
just like no and I was like what do you
mean no no like they said no and they
were pretty clear about it and I was
like um you know what just give me the
email address because if it's coming
directly from me nobody's gonna say no
to me
Saima bob forever cigs i write an email
to the publicist and they're just like
no and I said well is will he when will
he be free I'll schedule around him and
know like this won't be happening
they were so [ __ ] cold it was crazy
like every once in a while you know
somebody [ __ ] smacks my ass back into
place and I remember what it's like to
not be Kevin it [ __ ] sucks man it's a
world of know out there mark I'm just a
yes so he wants to do anything for me
and then I had to [ __ ] deal with the
fact that like a dude who I've loved my
whole life wants nothing to [ __ ] do
with me and then yeah it was crazy that
was nuts man that was like being my dude
would have gotten like the interview of
a lifetime like I was the legit and
still am I it's not like I stopped being
a fan but I do understand that yes zero
[ __ ] taste with me but like he would
have been like you know me when I'm
[ __ ] like an been [ __ ] podcast mode
I make a [ __ ] seem like they
invented whatever the [ __ ] they do it is
the slob raised interview ever my
warmest way it's a love fest but they
were like you don't want your love all
right fair enough it's like being
blocked on Twitter before there's a
Twitter and you dunno know kids like oh
wait you block why did you book what did
I say that made you want to block me I
don't know which way people swipe for no
but he [ __ ] swiped that way very he's
held it down I'm sorry Victor Garber I
don't know what I did but like my god
I'm a fan all right so more guests in
the future is what I'm getting at but
probably not Victor Garber what did I
say then I really loved him in Titanic
rot he was in it what happens if I reach
out to Victor Carper to say hey man you
could be on my pagas like oh of course I
would love to honestly do it let's find
out then we'll find out how much Victor
Garber hates me and then we could create
a new Park a podcast called how much
does Victor Garber hate every week if
you have like he still hasn't come on
and this is episode 1 if you were like
would you like to be come on my part
would you like to come on the Battlestar
Galactica pocket well I've never been in
that show but I would love to was like
now he's just doing it on purpose
all right so guests that's what we're
getting Victor Garber please I feel you
Johanna he saw that he'd be like what
like I did that in the seventies and
[ __ ] oh well okay I only don't want to
do this podcast and I can't always get
what we want mark and sometimes you
can't even get Victor Harbor which
really sucks because I was trying hard
man all the things I thought we were
gonna spend 20 minutes talking about
today Brecht was still on the line
because that'd be like Breck have you
come across Victor Garber in this
business yet w parties what the [ __ ] is
up with that Breck what you think we
think Victor Garber has kids maybe
it's like I I don't I just drew your
podcast title I don't know you guys at
all I feel like every episode we have
asked I guess we have to ask them if
they can get to Victor Carper do you
know anybody that who's Victor Garber
[Laughter]
yeah I do why they like don't you know
Ben Affleck didn't he put him in a heart
go I was like and it didn't work for me
so going around the bend
gotta go around all right [ __ ] all that
I'll deal with that with my therapist
when I'm sitting there going I don't
know why Victor Garber doesn't like me I
mean I try so hard
I'm his Victor Garber [ __ ] Victor
Garber won't answer my calls Victor
Garber will listen to me and doctor goes
well just you know you might want to go
watch a Victor Garber movie I'm like but
doctor I am Victor Garber that is
already more than I've ever said the
name Victor Garber in my Victor and or
mr. Garber Victor Garber makes and
Victor Garber I'm like
Jesus from Godspell don't be an [ __ ]
he was in Titanic as well
captain Thomas and regatta designed the
boat yeah he's there he's the engineer I
built a good ship few rows I promise you
won't sink dude don't jinx it let me
tell you something now I'm glad he
wasn't on the podcast because I didn't
know that and so like I would have been
ignoring like one of his biggest roles
little time we need Todd back in 79 guys
like you realize I was in the one of the
biggest movies of all time right I'm
like getting game he's like no Titanic
I'm like one of the biggest whatever
yeah nineties yeah let's just sit here
and stare at each other breakthrough our
conversation so is this podcast is going
the web sitting there like shoulda
listened to my [ __ ] publicist right I
said no twice I don't even know what I'm
doing here third time's the charm I says
to myself no no no he seems to know
Joanna from [ __ ] Sweeney Todd I said
I'd come on the show what a waste the
time seems really big fan but no sing at
me you know I like and respect Ben he's
usually very smart but he did the wrong
thing and picking this idiot
all right there's enough of the [ __ ]
Victor Garber antics we gotta get down
to a show nobody tuned in for this
although three hardcore Victor Garber
fans out there who are [ __ ] dying or
like best show ever bored Garber humor
I'm a Gerber baby - all right so [ __ ]
all that we gather together to ask the
Lord's blessing ladies Jim we were
chasing and hasten his will to make
known and we come here once a week in
this gathering spot because we want to
know what's going on in the businessman
one of us used to be a news hound [ __ ]
apparently got no leads on Victor Garber
but [ __ ] he's tracked down news is you
can't get me garbage a great Caesar's
ghost what do you mean he said no again
oh you know what I watched before we
jump into news so I did watch along yes
for
Warner Brothers of Superman dock look up
in the sky and it was wonderful man
because it's like a whole walkthrough
you know Superman's history up to
Superman Returns because this I guess
was a feature on the DVD or something
like that and so they're doing this DC
Tuesdays thing where people like they
watch along and [ __ ] tweet along and
they're like you want to do this
Superman talks oh my god absolutely so
whose fathers blast while I was doing it
but as I'm watching it like you know
you're going through the history of
Superman and from the comics and all the
TV shows and movies and stuff
number one made me really want to watch
Smallville really Oh like I was like are
you [ __ ] me is this what Smallville
was like I really missed out jason was
always telling me is like you gonna
watch footage Smallville is like does he
wear the costume he goes no and as a guy
watching it no flights no tights exactly
and I feel like I missed out man I
really do based on what I saw but I want
at the end of it then they finish up in
Superman Returns and you know Brandon
and and not hopefully so at the end of
the thing I was like [ __ ] I you know I
haven't seen this movie literally since
it came out I'm gonna talk him wash it
again so I kicked back and it was like a
cheap rental man it's like 99 cents I
think and I watched Superman Returns on
iTunes yeah was last time you saw
probably like back when it was out like
probably when it first hit cable after
release its it's like it's beautiful
it's like Bryan Singer was never there
we should ask Olivia Munn how often he
was on that it's like a beautiful
looking movie shot within an inch of its
[ __ ] life gorgeous and it means well
you know what I'm saying it really does
but like a lot of enthusiasms I forgot
in the third act like my big issue with
it when I first saw it back and it
wasn't a big issue but I was like how is
that like at the end like you know he's
fighting lex luthor but he doesn't fight
lex luthor he's got to pick up spoilers
that kryptonite island you know that's
you know blown up out of the water and
threatening metropolis and the rest of
the continental United States so at the
end of the day there's
no like there's no punching it's it's
literally the the antithesis of Man of
Steel's third act where he fights
everybody you know is a you Zod come
here you the lady come here you Louis
let's go like he just
there's fight II fight actions bodies in
there oh my god it's crazy it's like
it's I remember watching that movie the
first time man steal and be like alright
well he beat Zod so it must be over let
me get my coat and then another twenty
minutes where they destroyed the city
I'm like this is [ __ ] action Superman
Returns is like the opposite of that the
third act like he punches an island
that's the big like he fights the island
he cuts it with his lasers and takes up
to the chest of will yeah which is like
an I ain't taking anything away going
like I you know but he's Superman
so at the end of the day like let's but
then again like this this movie is is a
love letter if there ever had been the
77 dick Donner Superman very much and
the end of that movie is not I'm going
to lift an island into the sky it's I'm
going to race around the earth a lot
there's no punching at the end of
Superman movie good point
it's here's a guy doing an incredible
athletic feat which I guess is what they
did in Superman Returns they were so how
come on was okay with him spin and to be
fair not technically all the way okay
even as a kid I was like kid [ __ ] do
that but then somebody told me years
late like in my mind when I watched that
movie he spins and the earth reverses
and goes backwards right and that turned
back time which I was like even as a kid
I'm like [ __ ] even one of his
[ __ ] powers and [ __ ] but somebody
told me they're like no you're being
literal when he went backwards he went
back in time he didn't turn earth
backwards and then like [ __ ] like
that in no way is how I read that yeah
that's what I said I'm like what are you
talking about he lit they literally
represent it like cuz the earth stops
and then search goes in the other
direction so I mean you know and I met
dick Donner and I should have asked him
like number one I should have been like
do you know Victor Garber and then the
I think I should have asked him is let
me ask you something what did you mean
with that whole spin in the earth
backwards was it literal was that like
you know [ __ ] him if the do you think
if we turn the earth in the opposite
direction time goes backwards was that
the thesis of the film I thought that's
as far as I know it might you know but
he's done it before he was like I made
that movie in the 70s grow up Kevin yeah
I wasn't so much acid it do you what is
your read on that seat on there spinning
the earth he absolutely makes time
reverse order and then he puts the earth
going back in the right - right it's
like he's just like he moved the dials
of the clock back to before Lois Lane
dies and then moves and started back
forward so that he can save her but why
not give a [ __ ] about anybody else but
wait but why did he start it all right
so you rewind it mm-hmm and then you get
it start he didn't go back to the future
so wait let's let's [ __ ] with this
percent okay Superman is in what let's
do it here you and me right are like
holy [ __ ] our wives [ __ ] fell into a
crevasse in the desert and make it dark
sure so we got a [ __ ] turn back Tom
yeah Victor Garber fell into a crevasse
in the middle of the desert oh my god I
would physically turn the earth
backwards to save his life and he still
wouldn't be on my pocket feeling why I'm
like because it's the right age the
right thing to do and B maybe he'll
finally be on my podcast look not bloody
likely
but watch what you say you won't know
you saved him all right so you and me
are here in this moment in time yes but
we have to go back and JC can you grab
me a water man my I was gonna go an
event happens in thank you in the recent
past yeah we got there too late yes is
what happens to Lois Lane yes you know
he's busy he leaves that present moment
in time yes and he goes back in time
right flies into space
screams around the earth like a thousand
billion times as you do and the world
stops on its axis goes the opposite way
on its axis
everything kind of like sucks back up
and you see like trains coming back onto
the tracks and you see the rocks that
had [ __ ] collapsed in that dam come
back under their tracks and then it
stops again and then he spins it going
forward
and then so what does he does he do all
that other [ __ ] again and save all those
other people or does he just live in
that moment from where he stopped time
because technically he's a time traveler
he left a place and then doesn't go back
to that place he lives in the what is
then the present right like technically
there would have been another Superman
yes that's yes that's what I'm getting
at right one that failed and maybe what
he should have done is go back in time I
beat the [ __ ] out of that Superman for
[ __ ] up well there's that there's
only the Superman who did everything
else but save Lois Lane yes who still
does everything else but save Lois Lane
and he now as Superman mark to yes is
able to save Lois Lane when Mark one
couldn't so for a brief moment in time
there's two Superman does he know that I
don't know if he knows that I mean did
Dick Donner know that again cocaine is a
hell of a drug this is probably modern
thinking right like it nobody in the 70s
was okay there'd be two Superman you
know the seventies like [ __ ] you we had
math and science man astral bodies work
man we [ __ ] sin Voyager was there
even space by now so did men on the moon
you know about some [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] him
you don't think we could have we figured
that out do you so when he turned time
back did he then get rid of the second
missile the one he missed because that's
what created the accident or does the
missile go back in the woods wait
because the reason Lois dies is because
one of the missiles hits hits he sounds
the one going to New York he misses test
back oh my god he saves because she's
like Lex my mom lives in and it's in
Jersey yeah Hackensack my mom lives in
Hackensack and he looks as watching he
goes like that not anymore I remember
being a kid me like now that's [ __ ]
evil
that's cold blood we live in New Jersey
[ __ ]
also like he's been having sex with her
a lot in his like weird underground
under Grand Central Station still he's
like your mother's gonna die yeah oh
yeah by the way your mom sorry not so
much and that's what makes him evil you
know he doesn't care about killing
millions of people maniac Lane miss
Tessmacher it was so awesome though that
like if like I rewatched Superman as
well after that so I watched bolt I
watched Superman and then I watched
Superman Returns and or vice versa or
Superman Returns and I was like I gotta
I gotta watch Superman no no I back and
watch Superman and it's just so [ __ ]
beautiful everything about it is
beautiful it's the template for the work
they still do today
all those Marvel movies come from the
template of dick Don or Superman all
those CW shows come from the template of
dick Donner's Superman is wondrous peace
and Tom mankiewicz who never gets a lot
of credit he's got it wet it's way to
get some shine but yeah like the First
Avenger is very much of the Superman
mold which is we're gonna tell the story
on ironically he is going to be a good
person without any issues like he didn't
have a dark side you know he doesn't
have any [ __ ] skeleton in the closet
he's just a good person who does the
right thing because he was taught as a
child to do the right thing
yeah it's true and so open oh but he's
got a bad guy in Superman is Lex Luthor
he's just not like a superpower bed
right but like he's not conflicted you
know in the way that you know your
modern superhero would be like well I've
got this tragic past yeah but it's not
is that affecting me that way I'm not
colored by it I'm not an antihero in any
way somebody put up online like in the
Twitter discussion you know a gift for
jiff of the moment where Christopher
Reeve you know he's like doing his Clark
Kent thing and then he takes off the
glasses and his [ __ ] that's my single
favorite moment it's just so beautiful
because like it's so like in terms of
performance you know it's not like
they've CG the [ __ ] out of them like
what you see like you know Mark Ruffalo
become [ __ ] that's my secret kappa
mall ways angry and then he turns into a
[ __ ] visual effect and [ __ ] this is
literally just a guy going from like
this
- yeah he gains like four inches of
height and instantly change his
character like suddenly you're watching
it go and they should have paid this
[ __ ] twice played characters you know
and like that every time somebody will
talk about either you know studios or
fans or whatever so yeah you can't do a
[ __ ] Superman movie like this well
you got to find a way to darken it up
I'm like [ __ ] you just don't like
that with that guy
not with that guy like in its and it's
all in the performance you don't have to
give him more to do I mean and I think
that that movie might have been the
first time that introduced the love
triangle between Clark Kent Superman and
Lois Lane yes it hadn't really been part
of the story going forward it was just
you know hey alright I happen to be
another person but we're both kind of
getting along and we just happen to be
work buddies and why are you never here
when he's here it was a mystery not a
love triangle world's worst reporter
Lois Lee he's been right next to you but
the 35 biggest story in the world is
sitting right there pushing his glasses
up but yeah that is always they like if
you can find an actor who could pull
that off just the I'm going to commit to
this just so I can do this once and his
demeanor just becomes like you just you
know it's that moment where you're like
oh Clark Kent as a character that he
[ __ ] plays just like remember in Kill
Bill where's like Clark Kent is
Superman's comment a commentary on
humanity how does he see us he sees us
as weak Jesus is inferior [ __ ] small
love that scene the two killers and [ __ ]
like that oh my god I love that movie of
the to kill bills I love them both but I
love volume too because it was the first
time you saw Quentin for my money do
something completely [ __ ] different
than he'd ever done before he did a
family film yeah he did a [ __ ] you
know a broken marriage drama like you
know and just said it against extreme
situation City drama yeah Kramer vs
Kramer but with like blades and [ __ ] you
know what I did last week after after we
did the show we sat around here in the
scum and villainy and we talked about
the mythic Street apart yes I watched
the mist did you yes I didn't hold up
[ __ ] good
that movie is dark oh my god does not
have a happy end the last five minutes
of that movies
such a mindfuck where you're like no no
and like what's his name of the lead
guys Jane
Thomas Jane Tom Jane [ __ ] going like
it was so [ __ ] real you know some
actors are probably just like that but
this dude literally looked haunted like
like that's the kind of screaming you
would do where you get one out could you
like oh my god the thing that I've just
done and you get the scream out and then
you have like four seconds where you
[ __ ] remember what you did and then
the next scream comes it was a haunting
[ __ ] flick man remember the moment
one girl like if she's like Sam Witwer
like in the scene and they're like you
know you should call me blah blah blah
and she gets stung by a bug her face
blows up and she's out see you it's
crazy man anyway but now based on that I
might watch Kill Bill I when I get home
I would I'm still waiting for the the
rumored legendary like Kill Bill Vol 3
with that mega cut yeah well no because
I remember that there were scenes or at
least this was rumor at the time was
that there were scenes that they shot
with with Vivica Fox his daughter
because there's a whole sequence where
she says listen you're gonna get of age
there's to be time when you feel some
kind of way about what just happened and
if you find that you actually want
revenge come find me and three we're
supposed to be about that girl luckily
you're not saying they shot something I
shot a scene or two with that little
girl right at that time but it was all
supposed to be about that girl at 23 24
years old who goes after Huma Thurman
for having killed her mom number one I
remember that scene but I had forgotten
number two I now demand this movie I
won't wait I know he's like I've got one
more film coming [ __ ] you it better be
this yeah I want to see the movie that
Marc just described that would be genius
who plays the character who plays Vivica
Fox his daughter at this point she's
gotta be how old about 2023 Huma Thurman
could be the same age she is right now
Thurman is what am i feminist so I guess
that's it so he Kravitz good that'd be
cool right that'd be cool got a look at
the killer about about to be Catwoman
mm-hmm who else
nice array she'd be funny and she's also
she seems imposing yeah
Amandla Stenberg who was in they hate
you give she's great right [ __ ]
Willow Smith if you want her get Big
Willie Stiles's kid whip your hair back
and forth
yeah call her how do you call her whip
your hair back shows up it's like the
bat signal um I want to see that movie
that's good idea no no I mean it's not
my name is Quintin well come on quietly
and come through with your promise I'm
getting married and having babies make
Kill Bill Vol three for heaven's sakes
he's got a kid man oh good for him
yeah I just had a baby all right we
gather together ladies and gentlemen
because we like to find out what's going
on the news and Mark has gathered some
news for us mark hit us with the news uh
the first one I'm going to declare
officially a rumor because I found it I
found it reported on the site that I
trust but the source was from the site
I've never heard of before okay
the rumor is that Disney Plus and Marvel
are developing an iron heart live-action
TV show are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me so
like RiRi
yeah RiRi Williams for those that fog I
was about to explain [ __ ] iron heart
to people that watch fat man yeah Wow
really yeah so wait a second mark hmm if
you're doing Iron Heart
yes and it's a Disney plush show
potentially isn't this possibly a
vehicle also for Robert Downey jr. what
did they do in that story in the comics
he's still around wasn't he he he she
takes up his name she attends his or his
armor I think he disappeared for civil
war to leave vanished for a while and
like there was no Iron Man and so she a
fifteen-year-old girl engineering genius
attending MIT found she built her own
suit based on the Iron Man armor and I
think of course like [ __ ] Tony Stark
comes back
from the dead or from where he was in
civil war - and so then she becomes Iron
Heart and has her own adventures and
stuff but you know there's absolutely
the world in which he's [ __ ] Jarvis
in the suit it could yes that would be I
would give him all the [ __ ] money in
the world just to be a voice-over artist
you know what I'm saying
like [ __ ] here we'll give you [ __ ]
20 million bucks for a season of this
show you don't even have to be on camera
nope we just want to hear you you are
jarvis just like we never saw a [ __ ]
jarvis until we may damage Arvest until
we made a vision you be our voice of
Jarvis that would be worth every [ __ ]
penny then you cast anybody you want in
the show anybody nobody's gonna be like
their friend not famous enough and [ __ ]
be like yeah well guess what guess who's
here the narrator is about as [ __ ]
famous as it gets I mean the other the
other way I remember when when Black
Panther had come out there was talk
about sort of rejiggering the iron heart
story and making it so that Sheree would
become Iron Heart Oh like I'm not she
becomes Lady Black Panther I think there
was a nice lady Black Panther the Black
Panther I think there's like stories in
the in the comic continuity where that
precise thing does happen but there was
in the MCU there's this conversation
that like what cuz they got [ __ ]
chadwick boseman I'm not gonna ruin him
anytime soon right so like but if Downey
is going to go away and you need
somebody an army to take some [ __ ] on a
little shade at the goopster he even did
it with my mouth [ __ ] Regina candles
all sorts of shade but wait a second so
the talk was it was like couldn't Sheree
also do that she wears that actresses
name oh [ __ ] she's amazing I just we
watched I told you like last week over
you watch Black Panther she is the light
and she's so [ __ ] phenomenal in that
and she loves her brother so much I feel
like I am going to be called upon to
turn in my black card I know because I
didn't even call touch of that mark
shouldn't you know there's I pulled
[ __ ] Victor Garber out of my ass but
I can't remember sure you know Victor
Garber me Sheree you don't know what's
her name somebody pull it up latisha
right
she's so I'm so sorry Graham so amazing
I feel I feel awful blurs that I've
betrayed us I don't think anybody judge
you for that you know what there's a lot
of Avenger you can't know all their
names like there's a lot of [ __ ]
Avengers of them meanwhile so many of
the comments is just naming them all
that's true thanks guys
alright so on look I know you're looking
for my permission I'm ok with this kids
not take becomes yeah oh my god I wanted
that show but I really want Robert
Downey jr. to be her Jarvis boys that
would be pretty great yeah in other
words the show where we take good shows
and somehow make them better with wishes
you know that show even better Robert
Shaw from Jaws who's dead can we get
them back somehow
yeah time money or reality we made it
better hey man is Kevin Feige and Disney
they do anything at this point yeah you
know I'm gonna give it a few more years
I'm gonna march into those offices it's
gonna be like Oh what Kevin do you want
to make a movie I'm gonna know I've been
watching you guys make movies for years
your miracle makers know like yes I was
like I want you to bring my father back
from the dead I'm like yeah do it
[ __ ] I've seen you pull off way more
impressive [ __ ] than bring him back the
dead I've seen that man DeLorean [ __ ]
360 room [ __ ] bring my dad bring my dad
back please Kevin buggy all right what's
next
speaking of comic book movies movies
based on comic you speak about him I
don't want any more you just watch
[ __ ] it out talk do you remember a
comic book called ball and chain mm-hmm
from there from the 90s Kyle
I laid Garza was the artist and it's
about these two superheroes that were
married and you know they're sort of
struggling in their marriage and then
the both of them get bathed by some
cosmic [ __ ] radiation and their
powers will only work when they're
within like six feet of each other but
do they hate each other so they've got
to be supposed to be like mr. mr. Smith
meets whatever super ears Disney is
actually it's not Disney it's probably
going to be Netflix but so the news
story here is that Disney is not making
something no cuz they make everything
but the two stars of it are going to be
Dwayne Johnson and Emily Blunt who have
just are you [ __ ] me
no not at all who created ball and chain
Scott Lobdell good old Scott littell who
was an x-men guy back in the day and
[ __ ] like that yeah so Scott Lobdell
yeah you know it was probably like oh I
[ __ ] like you know ball and chain was
so great when we did it back in the day
but it's a Marvel and DC world now and
now it's not now it's a comic book world
where they're just like we'll take any
[ __ ] IP how happy must he be be like
are you kidding me those people yeah
it's not only are you making in a movie
but it's good those [ __ ] people oh my
god I won the lottery that's tremendous
yeah cuz they did be our TV show movie
movie for Netflix which is I think the
rock ayuk stuck on the rock you know we
have it like that he just finished or
was in the final stretches the finishing
illegal red notice for netflix good
netflix i think we like this rock we
think he has some potential let's maybe
make another victory you see was popular
with the kids it's speculative but bring
him back well we'll use his option but
yeah and the book had been in
development a couple different times as
TV shows yeah seems like it lends itself
to episodic instead but hey man you got
those two you're making a movie you got
a Stu pal that sounds fantastic
yeah no and I'm very positive kids
always very positive except for Victor
sub yeah [ __ ] god I can't get any
positivity out of that guy you know I
saw somebody online was on Twitter
go figure I was saying [ __ ] about me and
they said that I'm a shill they go he's
a [ __ ] shill I mean like kids I'll be
honest with you I wish I was a shill I
wish there was such a thing that they
gave people like money to [ __ ] say
nice things I have not encountered that
view no no I remember like those those
accusations have been levied more than
once and it's like ah man they just
[ __ ] get paid by DZ like stuff it's
like I know but sure
well if they want to I wish look let
them know I'll take their money and [ __ ]
that'd be amazing I like everything
anyway so they're like we'll pay it'll
like this I'm like I liked it anyway
easiest money you've ever made yeah
don't think this is all just fandom this
is just [ __ ] I like and people get mad
when you don't like [ __ ] like that they
don't like but you can't [ __ ] like
that this is to be just like everything
I'm like one I like a lot of things I
don't like everything I'll say it again
for the gazillion time you'll never hear
about the [ __ ] that I don't like I just
keep that [ __ ] to myself but I'll tell
you all the live long day about the [ __ ]
I do like and I'll tell you what ball
and chain
I like it it sounds like a cool idea
they got a cool cast I'm [ __ ] in man
and I'm happy for [ __ ] Scott Lobdell
that's dope you know how I know he
doesn't say [ __ ] about [ __ ] he doesn't
like because we talked about an iron
fist for like nine hours and he was like
it's good to me even I couldn't come
down out of heart I was again but Marc
at one point they wore the face mask man
I was watching extraction and its really
great but I did at one point turn to my
wife and I was like you know what make
this better if he was dressed like
[ __ ] Thor like all they needed to do
is put him in a costume but you're
always [ __ ] but I guess not everything
could be a comic book movie now you know
what I did watch tell me
tangentially ragnarok not thor ragnarok
but there's a Novak series yeah that
it's Norwegian it was shot in Norway its
foreign language but I just watched it
dub because who we can but it's like six
episode high school drama about a kid
who moves to some town in Norway named
ed uh his name is Magne and and he's
driving in with his with his his brother
I think this is adopted brother and his
mom dad's nowhere to be seen and like he
helps us old lady across the street and
she's like does some wavy [ __ ] across
his face and his eyes light up and he's
like Thor reincarnated and like and so
he suddenly it's like I woke up
yesterday and I don't need my glasses
anymore and I can run no fast and I
found this hammer and I flung it and
lightning in the sky and it's a kid who
discovers that he's Thor and there are
[ __ ] frost giants who live in this
town but they're like industrial magnets
were like polluting the water with like
awful [ __ ] and it becomes this
environmental thing cuz this Norwegian
like it's like it's super quiet right
but it's also what if you were a god who
didn't know he was a god and had to go
through the meaningless [ __ ] of
being a high school student and like
doing reports and like falling in love
with a girl who's always gonna fall in
love with the frost giant because duh
you know and your younger brother who's
a bit of a [ __ ] troublemaker and I
was like jet black hair no whose name is
like Lawrence or something like that
who's like always [ __ ] he's just he's
he [ __ ] with you to [ __ ] with you right
and it's just these little tiny glasses
on Norse mythology and I found it so
[ __ ] charming and like moving at
times how many hips six six one our apps
what one our apps yeah you know like
it's called Ragnarok Ragnarok yeah like
super digestible and like it's always
interesting watching something as
mundane as high school life through the
prism of somebody who's not American but
is like how mundane Norwegian high
school this is awful but now you could
throw a hammer yeah what kind of Hammer
workman's hammer wasn't a big regular
hammer it was like a little baby
sledgehammer yeah
man man that sounds dope I'm glad that
you watch it that I don't it was uh it
was just with flibben [ __ ] Netflix as
one does like what is that oh gosh a
little trailer that automatically spools
like I get six episodes let's do it do
you think [ __ ] Disney at one point
was like we're gonna sue their [ __ ]
asses off and somebody was like their
[ __ ] predates your [ __ ] yeah what
actually it's like mythology's are
actually Norse you can't copyright Thor
we can try they believe in this is a
Marvel Comics this is their [ __ ]
faith you idiot yeah we can't call it me
on there I think that's Milner's there's
a farm owner was a Marvel you know do
you think you can get away with the show
in America but instead of it being
theory finds out he's Jesus in high
school where would people be like yet
you can't [ __ ] I think Netflix did
Jesus never a teenager yeah they did a
show called Messiah on Netflix which is
about this second coming and what would
happen on earth if suddenly Jesus came
back was there [ __ ] devil
I never wasn't like final conflict
disciples of the watch I was so [ __ ]
metal alright yeah so anyway moving on
speaking of comic books from the 90s
that are now suddenly becoming movies
did you ever read profit by Rob Liefeld
no but I'm familiar with the book yeah I
mean it's a he's a DNA enhanced super
soldier who was placed into cryogenic
freeze for a future mission only to
awaken prematurely in the president
should seek permission that does not
exist and then a ruthless bruiser cur
must find his humanity okay he created
it in 93 I think but it was a young
blood extreme universe muscly guys no
feet whatsoever pretty much lots of
bandoleros and pouches and pockets and
little places to tuck things and they're
making a movie feature film feature film
where companies called studio 8 I
believe which has a deal at Sony perhaps
I'm just making that word of it let me
tell you something I know a little bit
about movies mark barnard yes sir
they're fun this will make a fun Wow for
him another [ __ ] 90s kid coming back
with a vengeance man [ __ ] then it pays
to be a comic book guy from the 90s
right now in the [ __ ] present Scott
Lobdell good for [ __ ] Rob Liefeld and
it's being adapted by Marc Guggenheim
who did you know Marc we do know Marc
Marquez my boss once that's right he
works for mark on what carnival row
carnival row that's holy crap man yeah
he's he's he of the arrow and troll
hunters and legends of tomorrow and all
of that fake you when is and we know
where it's going so uh I think so but
that could be that could be premature
what was that for was it an image book
yeah part of the extreme universe
happy happy for those 90 cat 90s cats
those 90 kids
this is 90s cats good for him good for
Rob Liefeld he's having a [ __ ] big ol
the minute right like Deadpool and
[ __ ] Deadpool one into a bags for
showed up for a minute I think he sold
his extreme universe to Netflix I think
did he he was one of those cats he was
one of those cats
it was his Netflix wanted to buy another
person yeah alright well buy yours great
I got a hey anybody wanna buy a via
universe comes with a few characters
I'll throw in Jay Mewes if you feed him
what else we got Mark Tom Cruise who has
never found a challenge he wasn't
willing to throw his body at at full
speed no doubt is trying to figure out
he and Elon Musk's SpaceX are reportedly
working on a project with NASA that
would be the first narrative feature
film an action/adventure mind you to
shoot an actual [ __ ] outer space look
I'm all for it man dream big and stuff
and his the second half of his career
seems less about acting and more about
like watch me die maybe this will be the
one yeah if I could buy a ticket I might
not live through this so I'm all for it
but you know like are they gonna be
lasers I mean they're gonna be monsters
I would hope there would be out of
lasers or monsters and not just Tom
Cruise like slowly moving through zero-g
show me the money
Wow I heard about this this week but you
know well here yeah is uh Mars Chris
McQuarrie doing it so far nobody but Tom
Cruise and Elon Musk are mentioned well
I don't like Elon Musk's scripts and
only he's a very good writer there
there's my hot take yeah i but i'll go
if it's you know he teams up to Chris
Picard you see that last [ __ ] yeah
and they're shooting or they had been
shooting shooting back-to-back
he made a hell of a [ __ ] Mission
Impossible and that's like the 98th one
in the series so like to be good this
late in the game like he directed the
last two of them he did the last two
right yeah yeah they were very [ __ ]
plot having smart and [ __ ] like that
get him on board and then I'll follow
you to space or just let's let's make
this a part of a Mission Impossible
movie like I don't need a separate movie
I agree completely let's just make it
like Mission Impossible in space
somebody tell Tom Cruise set him up with
a meeting with Jon Favreau
I could tell them you know we got video
walls now we don't need to be you know I
shot the Mandalorian in my garage so I
don't know if you want to really go to
space yeah here's what we do we put you
in a mask it don't even have to be you
boy oh boy
like he's leaving no stone unturned in
this life isn't he
no no he's jumped on all the couches
he's he's driven through all the things
he's he's lived a life you ain't kidding
do you think like you're his kid if
you're Suri Cruise or you're like don't
go up to space dad what are you nuts you
might die up there like a little girl in
Texas you're gonna die up there she
pisses the floor I I would be terrified
I would save my dad who was a postal
worker as it said son I'm going to space
to do this job I would have been like
dad don't go you'll die up there and for
sure it's a bad idea somebody else can
do that you're not trained for this I
also don't think there are any mailboxes
in space
so I don't even know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about who are you
delivering mail to and what don't we
know that you do I'd be I'd be if I was
this kid I'd be like all right it's one
thing you want to tie yourself to a
[ __ ] plane but like yeah come on with
the space yeah what's the [ __ ] point
yeah did you see speaking of space did
you see the trailer for space force I
the trailer space force and then what
might have been an actual recruiting
film they both were funny
it looks fantastic I'm so in but it
looks like so like because it's like
literally like you know they do the
scene where he's like space forces are
good he's like which you're gonna run
he's like what no really that's the name
I look forward to it man yeah he's got
Lisa Kudrow in it [ __ ] love yeah
I've got Kokomo apparently yeah there's
Kokomo so that was fine
I wasn't like ahaha some people thought
that part was very funny I thought all
the rest of it was very very funny and I
thought it was shot really well too ya
know that looks great I'm on board
yeah I mean I'm not joining the space
force but is it match Lix
yes I mean I paid for it anyway so it's
freedom I'm watching what else we got
right along diggy diggy doing were you a
scream fan Wes Craven's scream not only
was a scream fan mark I'm a scream actor
I'm part of the Screen Actors Guild I
was in scream 3 me and J you're in the
scream universe yeah we're in the scream
of verse me and in fact here's a little
[ __ ] trivia story me and J did a cameo
and scream 3 is Jay and Silent Bob and
we shot at CBS Radford the studio and
while I was there when we were done we
shot with Great West Craven of course
who was very sweet when we were done I
said to Jay we're walking around the lot
and I was like this is [ __ ] cool man
we should do a whole movie where Jay and
Silent Bob are on like a movie studio
and lo and behold
and we went made Jay and Silent Bob
strike back not so long after that and
guess who I put in my movie as a cameo
Wes Craven Wow
life's like that kids too one big [ __ ]
square no circle the wheel in the sky
keeps on turnin just like journey told
us also said don't stop believin yeah
it's I I like scream very much in
speaking to Rotten Tomatoes to push
another project the Canadian drama
castle on the ground
starring Neve Campbell Neve Campbell
revealed that she's in discussions about
joining a new screen why wouldn't you
you know what I'm saying like if [ __ ]
Jay and Silent Bob can reboot you can
make a scream what would it be four or
five oh gosh five yeah they've done a TV
show did they do movies without her um I
think there might have been one without
her I think she came back for like four
hello Sydney
yeah that's smart that's that is a
no-brainer to me I met her once
yeah long time ago when I first moved
out to Los Angeles and we moved into the
my athlete you know the house I live in
now which was Ben's house she lived down
the road and she came to a party at her
house at our house and I was like where
she invited she just stumbled in my wife
she just came my wife would just throw
like throw parties and it's so crazy
because I'd never been that person and
even in New Jersey we'd never been that
person and like when we moved into that
house we just kind of inherited all the
people that used to party with him and
so Jen just kept the [ __ ] party going
and I'll never forget like one day that
[ __ ]
door bell rang and I went to answer it
and there were like six people outside
total [ __ ] strangers and one of them
was like holy [ __ ] it's Isla Bob and I
was like hey how are you like yeah man
we're here for the party
I was like oh who you with like well
nobody we just saw there's party going
on and I was like oh it's not that kind
of party we were just gonna let [ __ ]
strangers in the house like oh hi man
it's cool when you're [ __ ] left so
strange why did I tell that story Neve
Campbell never Campbell was one of those
she was one of the people I was like god
you're not invited is that Neve Campbell
you could come in yeah you were in party
of five get your ass in here I can't
imagine that life where like you would
just roll up to somebody's house and
assume that you could get in wouldn't
you be scared like just think as the
potential guests like what if I was like
yes come into my house and I close the
door and I'm like and they're like holy
[ __ ] and I left the one I'm like go
ahead run tell others that's what you
get for coming a bug a party you have
been invited to I stole that last move
from claw you know and [ __ ] in Black
Panther where is it going run away it's
the guy in the back that [ __ ] was cold
yeah I'll be honest with you he's
amazing in that movie it was a real
shame that they killed that character
off [ __ ] movie about him his circus
is awesome he is fantastic he's so he's
so gifted all right what is so yes Neve
Campbell is in discussions to join the
new film I'm all for this more of the
pet I want all the past to come into the
present mark although it'd be way better
if we could just go back to the past can
we do that mark can we go back to the
90s as soon as I learn how to fly and
then I can turn the earth backwards and
we can figure that [ __ ] out oh we sure
that's what happened in that scene no we
gotta talk to dick Donner yeah
Jamie Garba we gotta talk to dick Donner
and Victor Garber get him gonna get his
own call right now private seconds
Victor your microphones off turn on your
mic he can
oh my God he's actually finally doing my
podcast but he won't speak because
Monica Rosa
Victor I got a write a sign dead inside
don't hang up in frustration oh my god I
missed my chance with Victor Garber I'm
so close [ __ ] all right what else we got
as had been rumored and it's not even so
much a rumor we all kind of knew it was
true Taika Waititi gets his own star war
thank god there's some justice in the
world that guy's talented I'll watch him
do every anything and everything
including my wife it's so gifted and
[ __ ] that Ragnarok movie the good one
is not the longest series that you were
talking about we're Norwegian stars
anybody crazy
Ragnarok movie is just [ __ ] beautiful
and what is the the Georgia rabbit
there's that of course everybody seemed
to like that what we do in the shadows
but what was the movie the winter you're
the elder people winter people will hunt
for the wielder people yes with sam
neill some beautiful [ __ ] all right
so what is it what is he doing um no
nobody quite knows because you know as
secretive as they are there's no release
date for the movie but yes he's writing
it co-writing it with Christie Wilson
Karen's who co-wrote 1917 with Sam
Mendes Oh do you see that movie I could
see them and I liked it I liked it quite
a bit I think it was on my top 10 list
I'm holding now for me I got a real
[ __ ] bias against World War one I'm
like [ __ ] that war [ __ ] you yeah I mean
honestly like when they were like Wonder
Woman set in World War one I'm like wow
but they did a really good job so I
stopped lying also was there for like 13
minutes and then we moved on and it's
parties sometimes I hear myself talk out
loud and I'm like no wonder people hate
my [ __ ] guts you know they're like
[ __ ] whitey wood why do you hate
World War one so much and why should we
care I'm like because you know good
reason they didn't have superheroes such
an idiot one day one day I gotta grow up
alright so he that nobody knows that the
story is but we know he's got a
co-writer we know
a co-writer we don't know the release
date because he's got or love and
thunder that's coming up first yeah
directing a film called next goal wins
for Searchlight he's doing some cartoons
for Netflix right rolling Roald Dahl
stuff and to like balumbo Willy Wonka
cartoons and he's also producing a Flash
Gordon animated film for Fox hey slow
down
thank you only got two things going on
geez ah good for him and strike while
the iron's hot
[ __ ] nothing's hotter than Tyco YTD line
them up yeah but don't strike them no
don't mistake that statement don't
you're not supposed to strike the iron
he's the iron well does that mean
exactly just like I think it's a fortune
thing when like yeah it's like you're
making a sword and you gotta hammer it
into shape and so you can only get the
hammering when the iron is hot if just
strike while the iron's it's cold it's
just bangin metal the whole life I
thought it was about this ironing why
would you strike it at a time okay I was
like how my mom used to like throw water
at to see if it's onyx I never in a
million years would have gone to like
laundry I tell you I'm soft market very
soft boy my dad said it my mom said it
turned out to be true we're in the forge
of Empires and you're like but you got
to get the creases right so you got a
free when the iron's hot
I'm like remember Game of Thrones yeah
remember all the heroes I'm like hot pie
like Sam Tarly you guys go Sam went on
an adventure Sam killed some I I was
like I'm just gonna hang out here and
make this wolf brand everybody wonder
when I saw you back there we were both
prisoners I opened a bakery I'll be
honest with you his wolf bread that's
his clerks you know what I'm saying like
that [ __ ] wolf bread huh kids gave
him everything yeah saved him from
getting killed and I maxed out my credit
card to build this recipe and look and
he was still talking about it years
after the fact he was like Fred like yes
they're delicious [ __ ] remember your
[ __ ] wolf bread and he's like had
olives fries I don't think that's true I
think I'm figured of the group bread
have you had the group bread no is
Disney made bread like after guardians
galaxy and it was like a loaf of bread
loaf flatbread and it had olives fries
but it was so [ __ ] good you eat the
[ __ ] at a group a I would like what
[ __ ] chill how [ __ ] up is that for
a kid who loves that movies like that's
why they stopped eating yeah eat your
friend you love him right
eat him that's what you do you are Groot
he's transubstantiated body of group he
died for you religions were built on
less we are Groot actually I would
subscribe not for nothing [ __ ]
a tree comes from the earth right yeah
he's gonna keep on growing yeah and also
that's like natural [ __ ] it's organic
you're a vegan yeah it's like it's like
with like a Wiccan how they [ __ ] you
know it's a Wiccan vegan [ __ ] it is some
wicked vegan shape oh that should be the
tagline for Guardian Gallo's the galaxy
3 what can vegan [ __ ] people like well
I'm not going for that to that then I
don't like I don't want no hexes and I
like me our last story for this evening
is it kids get ready you've been sitting
there all night going are you done yet
just like my wife when we have sex and
now you're about to come to the end of
the show you are I
it all depends how you feel about a
Tigers and beat Nicolas Cage this is
this is good news as far as I'm
concerned this is good news it's it's
barely genre
it's barely nerd [ __ ] but it's a closed
cage who makes everything
genre Nicolas Cage is gonna get in the
cage as Tiger Kings Joe exotic who's
going to star in an executive producer
his first ever television series he's
gonna executive Bruce it - yep and he's
never been in a series he's never been
on television I mean well it's not like
there ain't no stigma now [ __ ]
everybody's wrong no but I remember when
I was at the LA Times I'd assigned a
writer a young buck named Josh Ruffin
Ruffus Berg Rotenberg to interviewing
for poplar know Oh Josh no he's the
antithesis of a football player but to
interview Nicolas Cage for some you know
she be directed movie that was coming
direct-to-video movies
okay it was like well why haven't you
done TV man like you could have been on
Mad Men you could have been on Breaking
Bad you could have Sopranos yeah I mean
you could have done any of these all
could have been yours if you wanted them
he's like you know every now and again
they'll come in with a TV thing it's
really really good but you know I just
the end of the day I'm a movie actor mmm
I just do movies like even the shittiest
of shitty movies to him is still a movie
and then he watched tiger kid he was
like oh that he was like I'm breaking my
last rule let's go let's do it that was
in the cage it's actually a really good
Nic Cage right there yeah
[ __ ] Hannah even without you speaking
I was like she's about to do in the cage
wouldn't go to brush in the hand was
doing all the work
my favorite Nic Cage is a hey my
snakeskin jacket never tell you this
jacket represents my individuality my
belief in personal freedom only about a
million times that's a wild at heart
[ __ ] of thank you ladies and gentlemen
and I haven't seen that [ __ ] in 20
years and I still remember that dialogue
man that's how many times I watched it
over and over again he is our best actor
he's hands-down the most courageous he
[ __ ] goes for it he's always
interesting he's like Meryl ensigns when
they're like you know [ __ ] why just
wing Merrill he's like I didn't make
sense to not swing or whatever the [ __ ]
he said like he just didn't want to sit
there and watch the ball go across like
[ __ ] this dude swings every time at
balls he shouldn't swing
I want him tilting at every windmill man
because that's when the genius happens
so when they announced this I was like
co-signed here's my money [ __ ] you
take all my money
I saw the internet did not agree with
this though the internet pushed for
eastbound and down Oh Danny bread
everyone was saying Danny Brides got to
play the guy what did you what are your
thoughts you know like I see it 100% I
see it like Danny McBride does that kind
of southern gothic weird very very well
right and he also has had mullets in the
past yeah but it's a [ __ ] Nicolas
Cage
right like I I don't think there's a
there's quite a better mate of subject
matter and actor in both the weirdness
and the oddity of both of those people
like dinner brothers just like it seems
to be well just a dude who'd be doing a
role yeah this would be some kind of
like exercising demons for a Nicholas
Cage yeah and I think that yeah that
dude would give it all I I can't wait
who's it for its for net hold on I've
ever but but but burn not Netflix CBS
Studios has the overall do you think
it'll be on the app on this might be on
all access CBS all access III maybe it's
a generational thing you know no saying
like because we're like Nick Cage and
then younger people like Terry McBride
yeah Nick Cage got a big ride I'm over
here going Victor Garber I can't wait
man [ __ ] I'll look I even swim that
when I watch tiger King I was like I
hear they're trying to like think about
making a fictional version of this why
would you bother like everybody is a
character in and of themselves they
could never do a justice with a cast and
then when they announce Nic Cage I was
like [ __ ] me in the mouth I was
completely wrong I'm ready to watch it
it is not the only Tiger king TV series
that's in the works what's the other one
there's another one which is was
announced late last year starring an
executive produced by Kate McKinnon and
she's playing Carole Baskin yeah mark
can't we put these two wonderful movies
and the other do two series together
right like we only need one of these and
kate mckinnon it i'm [ __ ] you got all my
money Silver Bullet kids team up come on
guys you know cheap producers out there
like [ __ ] you guys in your [ __ ]
podcast show we got millions riding on
this like yeah but we think it'd be a
better idea if you guys team Dungy mr.
Weese at the top of the show what we do
is we give you the news about TV shows
you make them better independent of
money and feasibility yeah and you know
who plays doc Victor Garber absolute
[ __ ] sure sold me there it is kids we
we gave you news we showed you star girl
we showed you the stars and then we
particular in the news and stuff are we
doing questions does anybody have
sure will do one question if it's good
maybe we'll do another oh there you go
yeah I am we gave a lot of show what do
you got JC hit us with a question uh
noir duelists asks I have been watching
gummy bears with my four-year-old who
thinks they are great what cartoon from
the 80s or 90s that hasn't already been
remade would you remake be honest with
him a good [ __ ] question yeah yeah
yeah legit and also like brought me a
happy memory of watching the gummy bears
mmm when I was a kid that was one of the
last like Saturday morning cartoons I
stuck around for it because that came on
like when I was getting older and like
maybe I shouldn't be watching course
never watch the gummi bears you know
they're bears they were friendly they
were do people eat them a lot they
didn't they like that's the thing there
was no like they just called them the
gummy bears but they had nothing to do
with the snack or anything like again
like make a kid watch a thing that he
loves and then like now what go eat it
[Music]
like that bears your friend put them in
your mouth put that bear in your mouth
these kids afternoon presents put this
bear in your mouth aka Disney's the
gummi bears and send me a dollar
can we change the title is just Disney's
gummy bears like I guess but sure that
was when Disney was like didn't they do
Darkwing Duck and [ __ ] tailspin and
yeah Scrooge McDuck duck and [ __ ] oh
those were the days indeed all right so
what 80s cartoon Dungeons & Dragons
that's the 80s cartoon they did a
Dungeons & Dragons cartoon which I
[ __ ] loved man I never played Dungeons
& Dragons but I'll watch the [ __ ] out of
that curtain so I say you could [ __ ]
totally do that because the kids got
trapped in like the Dungeon Master's
world with a real kids it was its new
high school kids who then became like
barbarian nymph like he made them all
[ __ ] whatever their roles were and
stuff I would do that one man cuz you
could totally in a post game of thrones
world like nuts man and also Vagan we do
that maybe we get in
by two Joe Manganiello this [ __ ] D&D
party hell yeah have you seen that he
has a party and he's got a wine cellar
in his house and he's turned it into a
D&D place his wife said go ahead and so
he has people come over and they have
huge [ __ ] campaigns III I want to go
because I'm particularly idea of Sofia
Vergara just being like he's downstairs
answering the door like I came I was Joe
here he's downstairs in his basement to
touch anything on the way down
thank you you're the richest person I've
ever met you never talk to you again
ting more [ __ ] nerds yeah they're here
for you another one this one's wearing
jorts and a hat sure why wouldn't he
invited me to come play no it was
intimidating because that's a big big
rollers you know it's like you know like
in [ __ ] Vegas where I wanna go near
that - it was my rollers a chair those
cats are literally the high rollers
who's never played before
you know what I'm saying you know up and
be like um I think I'm moving the [ __ ]
on and they're rolling it I'm not sure
what I want to go to more Joe
Manganiello sci-fi D&D dungeon in his
house or Tyrese Gibson Benihana that he
built in his backyard he has his own
Benihana he has his own Benihana
he calls it Gibson Hannah oh no oh no
yeah he's got like the [ __ ] flattop
and it's like he built a house back
there with his very own Benihana he's
got a chef that cooks like whenever he
calls I came in you gotta come a man
with a party and some most chef will
come and he sits there strangers have to
sit around it yep and you got the onion
volcano and everything I'm no therapist
but how much does Benihana have to mean
to you in order to replicate it into
your backyard because I'm not for
nothing mark but he can probably get in
a car and drive to the nearest Benihana
within half-an-hour and it's also not
like Benihana is the greatest thing in
the world I mean I don't want to pick
any fights but he's he's not wrong no I
was like it's fine yeah been to my share
I've had the fried rice I enjoy it quite
a bit and it's novel watching somebody
cook in front totally but if I'm going
to spend like 200 grand to outfit
something in my backyard it's not going
to be a bit
I know what do you think it's gonna be
you got $200,000 budget and it's like
Brewster's Millions we're like you can't
put it away you got to spend it on
something [ __ ] ridiculous your
backyard some dumb [ __ ] you gotta you
got it I mean the biggest ball pit
you've ever seen would be more fun and
like probably more men these days I
don't want that much germs in my own
backyard
good point [ __ ] that's a germ farm
you know what I'd build what a Star Wars
bar would you yeah you know I probably
wouldn't cuz I wouldn't want to get
[ __ ] with cease-and-desist but it's my
house this is my bike that's true be my
backyard Oh they'd find a way to cease
and desist you even in your own backyard
maybe maybe Flynn's arcade ooh some
great old like walk standing video games
and that is pretty tight that's pretty
dope basically it's I just want to
recreate my 12 year old life my best
twelve-year-old life if that's Benihana
man sorry I don't mean to cast
aspersions Tyrese like you have a good
time no Tyrese is laughing at us he's
gone you want to make an arcade
meanwhile I'm eating at my [ __ ] their
sustenance here but yeah there if you go
online on especially YouTube and search
for like Gibson oh you will see he's got
one he's got one giving a tour that's
how you know you've made it in life when
you have a Japanese yeah when you have a
Japanese restaurant your backyard indeed
transformers money man I don't even have
a convenience store in my backyard
because the convenience store did
everything for me yeah on brand I should
have built a quick stop in my backyard
it's not too late because I do like
selling things I could always work the
register and [ __ ] I'm like Tyrese I
wouldn't sit there and have someone to
cook for me I would demand to work the
register that's why I would have a
commune you should do it in your garage
so people can just pull up and you just
pull up the thing and suddenly it's like
quick stuff you know you laugh but this
is a good idea
you know not for nothing I could
probably get a few people to drive by
speaking to drive by you know Star Wars
day may the fourth happen this week of
course and we did our live streaming of
Empire Strikes Back watch along on the
stream but JC and crew were here all day
long so
burning star wars day and they were
doing this thing where you could drive
up to the front of the building
something you could never do in any
other [ __ ] time other than this
gorona world and [ __ ] where you can
drive up and get what would they call
could put a camera on you to say this
he's so proud of it doing it we call
them
scumbags what was it is so good what was
in the scum you had a brown paper bag
yeah that we wrote may the fourth be
with you on nice and inside you had a
glass of blue milk in a to-go container
booze are non booze Busey over because
they let you do that now people can take
booze and go dude booze to go wait is
that a quarantine thing it's a
quarantine thing what happens when the
quarantine ends do you think alike no
more given booze to go I think so do you
think the world's gonna [ __ ] you I'm
used to booze to go now I like going
backwards
you got a fruit roll-up a bag of chips
and a scum and villainy patches your
prize [ __ ] a man how awesome is that
and so many people over 500 people
[ __ ] rolled up yeah to get that like
in the middle of the day and [ __ ] like
that is fantastic and that was a lot of
support first coming villainy right here
place that we all love and I bet you all
at home loved it even if you haven't
been here yet and stuff and didn't you
also what cell what was a buscar' what
metal oh yeah we had these are we have
these special gift cards right now which
are metal like best scar steel oh listen
that metal kind of loosely based on
bisque are from Mandalorian it's got our
logo and your gift card numbers on the
side so when we opened back up you can
come in here and buy a drink or buy a
drink for another person in the bar and
throw down some bisque our that's pretty
dope man as like American Express to
release a best car card yeah black card
I want a platinum card one [ __ ] best car
Steve and then you bring it to a lady in
a helmet and shoulder blades where I put
it right here man as you can see I like
shoulder pad so come on [ __ ] right
here that all the news well
we're way late I know what is your 80s
cartoon it was 80's 90's the dude said
so I'm gonna go with galaxy rangers did
you oh yeah I I dug act I haven't seen
it since they first aired but I remember
the the opening credits were so [ __ ]
awesome the animation was so great
I was always taken by the idea of you
know so law enforcement in a frontier
but the frontier was outer space what
was that what Firefly was very proto
Firefly so it was pre fire but yeah very
much so
when you saw Firefly we were like they
[ __ ] stole from galaxy rangers really
like I remember jaws look so never
forget [ __ ] galaxy rangers man that's
your Pole that's my pole
here it is Mark Stone galaxy rangers I'm
doing Dungeons & Dragons yeah I'll be
honest with you it was an impulse Pole I
didn't really give it a lot of buzz in
every poll and impossible probably
should have said underdog we'll discuss
it on a future episode let's grab
another question since that one was so
good give us a question that is the best
scar steal of questions JC let's see
shooter 32 92 if you had to put your own
super team together what characters and
what roles would those characters fill
based on skill set
Oh meaning like you know one's a crack
thief one's a [ __ ] weapons expert and
[ __ ] like that it was like if I gotta
build an Avengers Who am I gonna make my
Avengers okay and I can choose from
anybody like yeah there's no stipulation
so just put your team together or you're
like you're D&D party superheroes I got
Jesus
I got Buddha who else do I got for I'm
going all the religions and all the gods
man like there's my super team and you
know their specialties are everything
because they're gods
- Shiva yeah Yoda yeah
the Beyonder nice cool Scarlet Witch and
like I'm dr. Manhattan smart nobody's
beating your team except maybe my team
when you fight each other to a
standstill
it's like Secret Wars what your skill
set whatever you need it to be yeah
everything I can do it all I need
somebody to pick a lock I can destroy
all locks everywhere what is a lock yeah
I just uh thought it a lock hasn't
existed yet what how do I fight you you
we already did and you can't yes I'm the
destroyer of worlds but I wanted what if
I punch you in the face
no what is a face like oh come on not
fair all right not a bad question last
one here we go yeah JC's got something
for it's gonna be electric Oh what is it
well might get dicey but we'll see if we
die see Oh what what creative talent
would you like to see do something in
the Star Trek universe see Howard 1992
said he would love to see Aaron Sorkin
write a Federation show like West Wing
in space I mean who needs an answer from
us that's a brilliant answer that's
fantastic so what is the question who
would we want to make a Star Trek Star
Trek yeah
Allah Tarantino I mean we have to make
Star Trek
well definitely him then give me it's
not fair but I want a tiger Star Trek
give me give me Taika Waititi doing Star
Trek oh my god it'll make the JJ the
antic nature of the JJ Star Trek seem
like the old Star Trek TV show
I mean basically it's like I'm healing
to get me as close as you can to Galaxy
Quest and I feel like tyka is the guy
who can get you as closest to Galaxy
Quest today that's true all right who do
I want to see do Star Trek David Mamet
rapid-fire dialogue what are you that's
my name what are you gonna do it the
thing what thing the thing the thing the
thing they had the thing well the thing
is the thing about the thing is well I
but you see I
I'm writing my that's legit David Mamet
dialogue That's not me trying to figure
out lines that's how people speak who
else who would Quentin for sure Star
Trek Star Trek very you know
philosophical so you'd want somebody the
sorkin thing makes a lot of sense keys
right some damn good dialogue for Oh JJ
Abrams out that happen
who George Lucas what would happen there
geez slower less intense Oh Charlie
Booker guy that does one mirror I mean
that's a mind [ __ ] of a Star Trek season
well everybody's sad everyone's scared
with the name of the episode that he did
there was basically Star Trek it was
like the USS yes that's [ __ ] that's
right was great that episode is true yes
[ __ ] so he beats you to it already he
made it he did that already happen well
you know me I like to wish for suit
that's already gone down whoo that's us
McAllister um yeah I would
I got one Spike Lee let's see uh Spike
Lee so Mike Lee's just like this just
like conveyor belts all over the
enterprise just yeah pulling
[ __ ] doing that gliding thing I
would like to see Phoebe Waller bridges
Star Trek yeah I back that yeah it would
be profane but it also be super [ __ ]
smart
yeah and just different yeah I mean has
has there ever been a woman in charge of
Star Trek Jerry Taylor was a producer of
Voyager okay but it was still like Rick
Berman at the time we're still
overseeing all the Star Trek TV shows
but she was the showrunner for Voyager
but feature film wise not as far as that
let's give it to a lady who'd be a good
lady to give it to I mean you did yeah
you just gave it to
the two biggest ladies in the business
what a good poll man never mind giving
it to one or the other they team up oh
yes and do Star Trek super ladies and
suddenly like you're [ __ ] jockeying
for space in the genre universe with
people that know every dialogue line of
scandal as well those people are
hardcore fans too man if suddenly they
were also Trekkies oh there'd be no room
yeah no no good question yeah well done
yeah looking nice man there's three you
know what I had no faith but three great
questions to get us the [ __ ] out here
Bam Bam Bam we're done just like that
it's all over
did you have a good time tonight kids we
sure did man [ __ ] on a stick it was a
good time thanks to our guest remember
we had a guest like we did some long-ago
Brecht Basinger man she was wonderful
don't forget to watch star girl when it
debuts I think she said May 18th check
local listings or whatnot but and thanks
of course to JC and Andrew coming out
and letting us do the show here helping
us get it out there for you all to see
and whatnot
don't forget this company is company
scum and villainy Cantina
will be coming back online as soon as
California lets it happen we're opening
in stages as the governor tells us and I
believe tomorrow is stage - yes which is
actually allowing for bars and
restaurants but only curbside pickup
which apparently that's what they're
doing
yeah little milking it on the curb and
sure they jump the gun when what a stage
three is when like people can go back to
bars and [ __ ] I thought stage three was
Thunderdome where we all just kill each
other yeah whoever lives gets to live
[Music]
we're so close we're almost there we
don't need another hero the yeah man
it's soon we'll be able to come out soon
the place will be open we'll be able to
do a show in person you know I'm sure a
lot of people like a year yeah yeah a
little Skype from home but yeah man
don't forget the scum and villainy
Cantina can they still get gift
certificates or no
yes gumming billoni cantina com click on
the shop link and there's all sorts of
fun stuff including the the that's still
around you can get an aluminium gift
cards yeah the best scar fuckin'-a man
there it is so if you ever wanted to get
a piece of steel in the mail JC's gonna
send it to you it's got his markings all
over stuffs gonna make you feel like
you're in the mandalorian then you stand
behind a video wall and [ __ ] you're
there do you see have you watch the
behind and scene no not yet it's dirty
pretty intense pretty wonderful we'd
also like to thank Victor Garber so are
we gonna have time for you yeah he's
waiting but we can't get to him we had
breakfast and you're honest ed I'll be
honest with you she wanted to be here so
yeah he's tied up at the moment next
week mr. Garber for sure thank you of
course to the guy to my left without
whom there is no [ __ ] show give it up
for mr. mark barnard and ladies and
gentlemen hush if you're looking for me
you could always find me at that Kevin
Smith Club go check us out or you can
find me right here that scum and
villainy Cantina doing this we'll do it
again next week and stuff who will we
get to Skype in next week I [ __ ] I don't
know man I'm telling you I'm it's been
this week going through my [ __ ]
rolodex in my phone people are like
what's a rolodex I'm gonna go through my
phone and I'm gonna start pulling like
[ __ ] names and Flint
Eastwood yeah you don't know me but
would you like to be on our show Victor
Garber mr. Eastwood hi
do you know Victor Garber thanks for
being here ladies and gentlemen don't
forget go make this week nice for
somebody don't even have to leave your
house to do it [ __ ] we had star girl on
our show she didn't even leave her house
and stuff so figure out something nice
to do for somebody this week and do it
maybe don't even tell them and stuff a
little nice quiet thing and stuff we
could all still look out for each other
even though we're stuck indoors and any
minute now they're gonna let us out and
we were like for free and then they're
gonna be like it's a double virus then
we're gonna run back inside
that's my prediction of the future just
run outside breathe a lot
go back inside go bacon so take a big
long fall and then
you know six more months of winter um
thank you for being here thank this guy
thank these guys don't forget ma'am
we'll be back in a week right yeah if
you want to be I think so I no place
else to go
makes me feel relevant that's right
we're gonna do the [ __ ] mayonnaise
version of the show my god oh my god
we're just gonna do all of officer a
gentleman remember how [ __ ] louis
gossett like made mayonnaise sound like
a dirty word because his name was Mayo
mayonnaise it he was so awesome won an
Academy Award
he was also awesome and [ __ ] jaws 3
but nobody gave me credit I'm an Eagle
cam shot he's like this caliber sawed
him and Watchmen he better get [ __ ]
nods this year it got nominated for a I
didn't even [ __ ] get to that point it
was it's on the the Peabody shortlist I
mean it deserves all the awards in the
world but like that cast was wonderful
they should [ __ ] he better get some
Awards this year he was great and I was
like oh my god forgot how great that
[ __ ] he does is nothing is right in the
world yeah I agree with him but
everything's right in the world now kids
because we just went through all the
entertainment news we possibly could and
now it's time for us to go man thanks
for hanging out with us here on fat man
I was gonna say they were about to get a
phone call from the Fox lawyer and I
just remembered that's a Disney movie
now they're the Disney lawyers and also
their that is a Disney movie sound of
music is always very Disney just didn't
happen to be Disney but now it is Disney
mm-hmm how weird it's so crazy I've been
you know we're trying to end the show
but I can't I predator versus Maria from
Sound of Music I've been watching so
much Simpsons on the Disney Plus no
[ __ ] go watch from season 13 on
every other episode there is a Disney
joke which like now plays hysterically
now it just sounds like biting the hand
that feeds but for years
they were always like poking at Disney
and now like Disney owns a man so
strange did you see that again we're not
ending the show yet but one of the
Simpsons writers I think Bill Oakley's
name is tweeted or retweeted a video
clip that basically says yeah I guess we
did predict coronavirus back in 1990
whatever and the gag is that there's a
there's a viral epidemic and whatever
the doctor the black dr. Cosby doctor
dr. Hibbert dr. Hibbert is like oh
everybody's [ __ ] who's the guy whose
name did you forget before oh
Laetitia Wrightson and dr. Hibbert and I
haven't watched the Simpsons in twenty
turn in your card yes but he's like
they're talking about a pandemic oh we
don't we don't have a cure for it it's
it's not in that van down there and
there's a fan that just pulls up and
everybody like that the Horde knocks
down the van and inside the van is a box
of killer bees first like no [ __ ]
around that's this year we live in that
world right now I saw video today online
cuz everybody's like murder Hornets what
the [ __ ] was somebody put up a video I
forget somebody tweeted and they were
like it was I think it was Christopher
Titus wrote like it was a video of a
praying mantis fighting a murder Hornet
[ __ ] yeah and the caption was praying
over murder which is kind of funny
but the video was [ __ ] horrifying
dude this praying mantis ate this
[ __ ] head while he was alive he was
like [ __ ] sure and he's trying to get
his tail like all [ __ ] if I could just
reach this brick but this guy's got
those arms and [ __ ] like that and he's
literally feeding on this [ __ ] head
and this thing continues to move even
though half of its [ __ ] head is gone
and [ __ ] like that all I can say after I
saw that thank god the praying mantis is
this small because holy [ __ ] we'd all be
dead man I remember like being as a kid
being as a kid watching kung fu movies
and like
a whole strain of them where there's an
ax there's a whole school of kung-fu
called like praying mantis style your
style crane style praying mantis is like
it's a [ __ ] bug what's a good oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] killer bug man yeah and I don't
is it praying or is it praying like I'm
gonna eat you [ __ ] like I always thought
when I was a kid it was praying because
it looked like they're praying but I
believe it might be this [ __ ]
predator ate my head said the murder
Hornet that's what we call it double
entendre sir I think so
words are fun kids I'm gonna homina
homina homina homina we have to end this
show there it is ladies and gentlemen
man Beyond I'm Kevin Smith and I'm mark
Creager
tune in next time same fat Tom same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith call me Victor Garber
[Laughter]
you